so I want to break down why I believe
NBS Muhammad Ben Salman may have a big
role in making the temperature in the
Middle East go lower specifically with
Iran Israel because if you are him and
you're very ambitious you're one of the
top 10 most powerful man according to
Forbes and you one of the most Charming
best personalities you're worth 25
billion you are the Prime Minister
you're about to be the king you got all
this personality charm salesman mavilon
he probably read the book Prince or 40
law of power he seems like that kind of
a guy but you are living in the middle
least and you want to get people from
all over the world to come to you for
tourism and yes you can say well saudi's
a very safe place and we have this and
look at Ronaldo's here Formula 1 and all
these other things that we're doing but
a lot of people still look at your
neighbors and say your surrounding area
isn't that safe and a lot of people say
they're not going to come over to you so
it's on you to do something drastically
that is unconventional for the world to
say I feel safe coming to you so tough
job but we got a lot of things we
investigated about this guy very very
interesting how he views religion in a
way that's controversial to many even in
Saudi we're going to talk about NBS
today okay so if you get value out of
this video give it a thumbs up and
subscribe to the channel let's get right
into it so here's what we're going to
cover we're going to learn about him
then we're going to learn about the
vision then we're going to learn about
the role Saudi plays in the Middle East
as well as world peace and then you'll
be able to make a decision on what you
think is going to happen with this guy
so let's get right into it NBS Crown
Prince of Saudi Arabia from June 2017
till today he the prime minister of
Saudi September 22nd until today and he
used to be the Minister of Defense from
January 15th to September of 2022 couple
of the things that he did with foreign
policy after he was appointed Minister
defense in 2015 he launches a military
campaign against Yemen blockade on Qatar
and efforts to counter Iran's influence
in the region so he's not afraid pushing
his Waiter on and saying hey I'm not
just somebody that's a young kid coming
up I am my own man I have my own
opinions I have my own philosophies I
want to lead building a reputation for
himself during that time Dom domc policy
in 2016 he drastically cut the powers
this is very interesting because as a
person who lived in Iran you have to
know there's a lot of power when
countries come up with this and he cut
their power listen up he cut the powers
of the C
pvpv which stands for committee for the
promotion of virtue and prevention of
Vice or better known as Islamic
religious police the feared cpvp which
had thousands of officers on the streets
and powers to arrest detain and
interrogate those suspected violating
Sharia and it was banned from pursuing
questioning asking for identification
arresting and detaining anyone suspected
of a crime this is very Norm when you're
living in places in the Middle East I
experience this personally when you're
living in Iran and I'm walking out with
my mother so for him to choose to do
this this is one of the way the
government puts fear into the people
it's like no we're not doing this
anymore controversial Cinema industry
changes it up was reinstated social
Liberties were expanded gender mixing
and dating have been normalized by the
state in public sphere 2017 corruption
perch another one of those things that
pissed a lot of powerful people up in
November of 2017 nearly 400 of saud's
most powerful people among them princes
tycoons and ministers were rounded up
and detained in the Ritz Carlton Hotel
in what became the biggest and most
contentious Purge in the modern
Kingdom's history this was after the
formation of an anti-corruption
committee led by Crown Prince Muhammad
Ben Salman imagine like you're coming up
you want to win the country over the way
he does it by bringing in the top 400
most powerful people and saying hey you
can't be doing all this corruption
anymore imagine what they're looking at
who are you to talk to us like this who
am I let me tell you who I'm going to be
here and what I'm going to do with Saudi
Arabia everybody realized maybe this is
just not another kid he's got a real big
Vision so look I've been in the
financial industry since 911 the day
before 9/11 and I've owned stocks bonds
mutual funds real estate crypto gold you
name it I've owned it but the one thing
that's very important part of my
portfolio all these years is gold I love
having a percentage of my netw worth in
gold that I have access to in case of
many different things a few facts you
need to know about gold number one the
gold market cap is $ 11.8 trillion since
2000 the compound annual growth rate for
gold has been
9.24% and during times of high inflation
3% Plus has been
15.35% now those are just some numbers
for you but there's some other benefits
to add gold to your portfolio number one
hedge against inflation number two
results showed recently that 93% of
central banks are working on AC cbdc so
this means what that could be a
manipulated currency that they own if
you own gold it's a non- duplicatable
asset you're now hedging against cbdc
taking place number three a potential
cyber threat if it happens you don't
have access to your money you don't have
access to your accounts well you have
access to your your hard physical gold
number four is anonymous no one knows
you have that gold and last but not
least diversification that's why we
chose to work with our new sponsor
American Harford gold if you have
retirement funds that you cannot afford
to lose American Harford gold will ship
physical gold or silver directly to your
door also if you have retirement funds
that you can't afford to lose now is the
time to call American Harford gold a
precious metal dealer you can trust they
have the finest products amazing
customer service and a buyback
commitment they've earned a five-star
rating from thousands of review and an
A+ from the Better Business Bureau tell
them I send you and they'll send you up
to $5,000 worth of free silver on your
first order so click on the link in the
description or call 866939 6984 again
866939 6984 so again anytime you have
somebody that's very ambitious you're
going to create a lot of enemies and
journalists are going to come out and
criticize you like well he's doing this
he's doing this and as a person that's
getting a lot of attention in different
places you handle it in a different way
in this case in 2018 and NBS Global
reputation suffered after the murder of
Saudi journalist Jamal rogi in the Saudi
Consulate in estanbul in 2018 the CIA
eventually concluded that he had ordered
the assassination a claim Saudi Arabia
denies this is something that the Middle
East says to deal with because in the
Middle East this is what people fear if
you want athletes if you want
celebrities if you want Stars if you
want all these people go to S I want to
go to the Formula 1 race I'm going to go
watch a wrestling I want to go watch
this they have to feel the safety to
know that these these types of things
won't happen this was a bit of a flaw in
his reputation and his Ambitions early
on in his political career MBS began his
political career as a special adviser to
his father who was then the governor of
Riyad his early roles in the Saudi
government included positions and expert
commissions of Saudi Council ministers
and Saudi cabinet his father's
ascendancy and key appointments his rise
to prominence accelerated when his
father became the king of Saudi Arabia
in 2015 shortly thereafter NBS was
appointed Minister of Defense making him
one of the world's youngest defense
ministers at the the time this position
placed him in charge of the Saudi
military and its ongoing involvement in
Yemen so now here's a vision 2030 that
he cast Okay in 26 and MBS unveiled
Vision 2030 a strategic framework to
reduce Saudi Arabia's dependence on oil
87% of the GDP diversify its economy and
develop Public Service sectors Davos in
the desert to track FDI this includes
ambitious projects such as neam a $500
billion planned Mega City that aims to
to be a hub for innovation technology
and sustainable living investment in
sports leagues investment in
entertainment so think about it when you
invest into entertainment are
entertainers mostly conservative or
liberal they're mostly liberal which
means if you want entertainment to come
to Saudi you have to be a little bit
more liberal than any other Middle
Eastern country which is kind of a isn't
that a country how you going to do it
that's not easy so he decides to give
Ronaldo $200 million think about your
Ronaldo's beautiful wife you guys got
kids Cristiano comes home and says hey
babe what's that I got a contract
awesome where we going Barcelona no
Manchester no where are we going uh
Saudi Arabia what are you talking about
babe yes we're going to take our kids to
Saudi we're going to feel safe there I
don't feel safe babe how about for $210
million let's take the kids to Saudi
Arabia right is what happens so he's
willing to give the money but the same
money didn't work for everybody Messi
became a Saudi Ambassador promoting
tourism in the country his contract
reviewed by the New York Times shows
that could earn up to $25 million for
his promotion over 3 years his deal also
angered Paris St Germain qari owners and
was contributing factor to as why he was
ousted from PSG Aston Martin announced
long-term strategic partnership with a
ramco which includes joint title
sponsorship of the British manufacturers
F1 team Liv golf announces an eight
tournament schedule for its new tour
which will include fourman teams
competing for 54 holes with shotgun
starts the seven regular season events
will have 20 $25 million Pur the team's
Championship will have $50 million in
prices it gets a little crazier with
golf live golf announcements it is
expanding its Team Series to 14
tournaments in 2023 would you ready $45
million in purses I think that's going
to draw a lot of golfers who want to go
golf there Bloomberg reports Saudi
Arabia's public investment fund explored
making a $20 billion bid you know for
what for the entire Formula 1 not like
One race for the entire Formula 1 in
January 2022 Liberty Media completed its
acquisition of the series for $4.4
billion in 2017 now Andy Murray says he
reiterates that he will not play in
Saudi Arabia I wouldn't play no I would
imagine it will only be a matter of time
before we see tennis tournaments played
there couple of the people Roger feder
turns down an invitation later saying he
didn't want to play there at the time
this is right after what happened with
kogi and at the same time John Cena from
WWE is removed from his scheduled match
days before he scheduled to appear at
Crown Jewel as the WWE faces Mountain
calls to cancel the event following the
death of kogi and this small golfer you
may know his name you may not his name
is Tiger Woods he turned down $800
million to stay with PGA why did he say
no to live for $800 million having said
that again anybody that has major
aspirations that personality is going to
be very complicated especially someone
that has the kind of power when you look
at oil reserves there's only one country
that has more reserves than these guys
if you look at this list from statistica
it's Venezuela 18% of the world's
reserves is with Venezuela
177% is with Saudi Arabia then you have
Canada Iran Iraq Russia Kuwait UAE but
Saudi you you are the person up there
you wor 25 billion at the lowest and
it's just going to get more and you're
given all this power and influence and
you got aspirations you got a vision
you're going to be a Target you have to
be accomplish licated person to want to
do something like this but when somebody
comes out and says the following I want
to read this to you Saudi Crown Prince
lambast his Kingdom's wahhabi
establishment let me read this to you
Crown Prince Muhammad bman has delivered
his sharpest attack yet on the Kingdom's
wahhabi religious establishment
declaring its Ultra conservative
interpretation of Islam out of date out
of date who are you to say this when he
said this he was 36 years old imagine
the people that are there 36 years
saying we're out of date and Alam based
on a faulty interpretation of Islamic
scripture speaking on National
Television in the midst of the holy
month of Ramadan he also defended his
promotion of secular Western
entertainment in the kingdom when I had
the Crown Prince of Iran Resa palon last
week his father in Iran the King which
he's about to be he was a young king at
21 years old similar to him he was a
very wealthy man very at one point CBS
called Muhammad Rara palavi the most
powerful man on Earth he was kind of
going like this trying to make Iran
similar to Western because he wanted
Frank Sinatra Elizabeth Taylor Sports
concerts he wanted that to be taking
place it's giv me The Vibes of wanting
to do that which by the way when he did
this a lot of the local people from the
religious sect called Muhammad rash sha
palavi a puppet of the West so he's
going to get criticized for that as well
to I'll give you more feedback here
again the whole part about the Western
entertainment in the Kingdom which he
had long condemned as heretical by its
once powerful wahhabi clerics and now
he's saying promoting of secular Western
entertainment which by the way so where
does the inspiration for this come why
are you all of a sudden flipping your
position from who you were to now
promoting secular Western entertainment
in the king what are you talking about
that's what the old school folks are
thinking about but here's where his
ideology comes from his ideology has
been described as a Nationalist and a
populist with a conservative attitude
towards politics and a liberal stance on
economic and social issues it has been
heavily influenced by the views of his
former adviser Saud Al katani and the
ruler of Abu Dhabi Muhammad Ben zad so
he has his own people he's looking at as
Visions but it tells me he's kind of
going through the Playbook of wanting to
do what the Muhammad did in so is that a
good thing or a bad thing here's the
reality of it if he is trying to do this
the number one thing he need us to have
with his brand is a word that starts
with the letter S cuz if you don't have
that people are not going to come to you
in the droves of Tourism that he wants
and what's the esort what do you think
Safety and Security we as tourists have
to feel safe going there if I told you
right now what criticism do you get of
going to duic Croatia you don't think
about threats or something happen to you
hey let's go to Vacation we're going to
go to Barcelona Spain you're not really
too worried about it but if you say
we're going to go to Saudi Arabia well
maybe why because it's in the Middle
East but saudi's not that uh problematic
it's it's safe yeah but you could be
living a safe house but if your
neighbors are problematic that region is
not that safe so he almost has to bring
the W safety to the entire Middle East
cuz that's what the Sha did in Iran when
when the Sha was in Iran for 37 years
the Middle East was safe they had good
relationships with Israel they had good
relationships with us decent
relationships with Russia decent
relationship with others decent decent
relationship and there wasn't chaos
there so to lower the temperature in the
Middle East I think one of the most
important pieces of that happening is
this man NBS he may be one of the top
three dominoes of making that happen and
he may even be the first Domino and when
you look at his allies and enemies the
top four of his enemies you'll hear Iran
you'll hear turkey you'll hear Qatar
you'll hear some of those names as an
enemy to him Iran's staying the way it
is and it's kind of Reckless and it's
unconventional and it's funding hezb and
it's causing mayem with Israel and all
the stuff that's happening does he want
Iran to be like that probably not so
maybe he wants to see a revolution
taking place there and maybe he wants to
see democracy being there not sure what
sect he wants it to be does he want it
to be religious like the way it was with
k or I don't know he doesn't give me
those vibes but very very interesting
character there's a reason why so many
people are curious about this man so in
order to do that you have to have
leverage over other people so what is
saudi's leverage over other countries in
the Middle East and worldwide well one
leverage that they have is you got a lot
of oil period they have enough oil
Reserve there's data showing when is all
the oil in the world going to run out
and I think if you go on the website
today it's 44 years 38 or 7 days and
some few hours left with oil reserves
going to run out except for Saudi you
know how long Saudi oil is going to last
you ready 221 years they're going to be
okay right with the amount of Leverage
that they got so the way to fight off to
not need Saudi is to go nuclear but a
lot of people don't want to go nuclear
and it's going to take a long time until
these other guys do so you're going to
need Saudi which what does this mean
when you're doing that well Saudi is the
biggest country in the Middle East
landwise but population wise they're
number five number one is Egypt number
two is turkey number three is Iran then
it's Iraq then it's Saudi so they don't
have the most people but they have the
most land they have the most oil and
they're in a location where they kind of
need to get the other people to kind of
work with them so there is a lot of
Leverage for NBS to be able to do this
but I think he's the number one dominer
that can make this happen so this
doesn't work if only he has leverage
which is good he has the leverage cuz
he's got something everybody wants but
there's got to be something everybody
else has on him for there to be an equal
exchange which is what he's very
ambitious and what's the word he used he
used the word defended his promotion of
secular Western those two words don't
get used in the Middle East and it's
supported by the elderly which means if
you want to do that you have to to make
it safer you have to get people like us
that want to come to 87% of your
country's GDP is tied to oil that's like
having a business that does a million
dollars a year but one of your clients
does 870,000 if that person you're
problematic if something happens there
right okay so he needs other business he
needs other technology he needs people
to want to move there he needs it to be
safe he needs entertainment he needs a
lot of different things there a lot of
exchange ship many different
opportunities if I was a president or a
leader of a country the first thing I
would say hey let's figure out where to
collab to make it a safer place that
people feel more comfortable moving
there what commitment can you make to
the world for us to know that what is
that going to look like that would be my
first step and I would look at making it
even more peaceful in other countries
around the area especially the number
one enemy that they have which is Iran
so if you got value out of this video
give it a thumbs up subscribe to the
channel if you are interested in the
Middle East we did a video a few months
ago titled are Muslims the angriest
people in the world and by the way you
would be surprised where Armenians rank
on that list if you've not seen it click
here to watch it take care everybody
bye-bye